je vous propose de commencer cette cette
séance de travail pour pouvoir tenir nos
agendas respectifs mes chers collègues
chers Catherine je suis particulièrement
heureux de la séance de travail que nous
tenons ensemble ce matin elle a été
organisée en liaison avec l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques l'OPEX
président comme vous le savez par Pierre
Aurier débuté de la Vendée dans le
premier vice-président et Gérard Longuet
sénateur de la Meuse elle réunit les
deux délégations parlementaires dédiés
aux outre-mer celle du Sénat et celle de
l'Assemblée nationale dans le salut des
représentants et leur président
actuellement sur son territoire sur un
sujet qui le mérite en effet amplement
je tiens à saluer l'initiative de notre
collègue Catherine progacia qui a été
membre de notre délégation jusqu'au
dernier renouvellement et qui a
participé à nos activités de façon très
constructive 13 ans après la publication
d'un premier rapport consacré à l'impact
de l'utilisation de la chlore d'école
aux Antilles elle vient de faire le
point dans un rapport publié au nom de
l'OPEX sur l'évolution des connaissances
scientifiques et sur l'état de la
contamination de de la Guadeloupe et de
la Martinique comme vous le savez cette
contamination résulte de l'épandage
massif pendant deux décennies d'un
insecticide ultra-toxique dans les
bananes compte tenu du caractère
gravissime de ce dossier dont avec le
président Larcher et nous avons pu nous
rendre compte très récemment lors d'un
déplacement aux antifas janvier il est
essentiel que la mobilisation
parlementaire s'inscrive ainsi dans la
durée je tiens donc à te remercier
sincèrement cher Catherine d'avoir bien
voulu te prêter à cette séance de
présentation et de questions-réponses
sur un sujet qui reste majeur dans les
collectivités concernées pour preuve
l’assemblée de Martinique vient
d'adopter jeudi dernier une motion pour
la mise en place d'une loi d'orientation
et de programmation dites loi
chlordécone avec l'idée d'une
co-construction de mesure avec l'État
objectif que nos délégations respectives
partagent largement dans les domaines
qui ne relèvent pas du régalien et qui
tient compte des enseignements
précédents
des précédents plombs mis en oeuvre la
collectivité territoriale de la
Martinique s'appuie notamment sur les
conclusions du rapport de la commission
d'enquête dans Justine Bénin était
rapporteur et Serge les Jimmy président
et qui avait pointé dès 2019 certaines
responsabilités et proposer des dés au
développement de nouvelles pratiques
agricoles saines et respectueuses de
l'environnement après sa présentation je
crois que nous aurons tous les
éclairages nécessaires pour avoir ce
matin un riche débat qui puisse préparer
les prochains développements de ce
dossier qui est assurément loin d'être
refermé je précise encore que cette
réunion se tient jusqu'à 10 heures
environ compte tenu de l'examen dans la
foulée du rapport sur la continuité
territoriale elle fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo et que nos collègues
ultramarins dont certains sont connectés
peuvent la suivre et intervenir en
visioconférence la parole de la torche à
Catherine
merci chers collègues je vous prie
d'excuser la voix
mais avec un micro ça devrait quand même
passer monsieur le Président tu as
rappelé le contexte de cette étude donc
je vous je veux simplement vous préciser
que à l'office parlementaire à l'OPEX
nous étudions les questions sur le plan
scientifique et donc on ne rentre pas du
tout dans le débat juridique qui est
aussi celui de l'argent déconne aux
Antilles tu l'as rappelé
nous avons en 2009 à lopex fait un
rapport sur la pollution les
conséquences que nous ne qui n'était pas
vraiment mesurée d'accordéon sur les
terres aux Antilles et à l'époque les
études scientifiques n'étaient pas très
avancées c'est pour ça que après 13 ans
nous avons souhaité à l'OPEX voir où
nous en étions en matière de recherche
et sur l'application des plans chlore
des codes alors en 13 ans il y a eu des
bonnes et des moins bonnes nouvelles en
2009 les scientifiques nous prédisaient
une contamination des sols entre 300 et
350 et 700 ans selon le type de sol aux
Antilles
dorénavant les études sont plus
encourageantes et elle démontre qu'il y
aurait une diminution
de la concentration nettement plus
rapide grâce aux flux pluviométriques le
Clos de corps déconne pourrait je dis
bien pourrait selon certains
scientifiques est inférieur aux limites
de détection actuelle avant la fin du
ciel ça marche pas
on va décéder
passer des clous
ces prédictions demandent naturellement
à être confirmés par la communauté
scientifique et vous savez comme dans
tout avec tous les experts et tous les
scientifiques ça divergent toujours un
petit peu mais en tout cas il semble
certain que la contamination ne serait
pas aussi longue que celle que l'on a
prévu n'empêche que même attendre 100
ans c'est encore beaucoup
cependant dans la moins bonne nouvelle
même si elle disparaissait des sols donc
de la terre pendant plusieurs dizaines
d'années supplémentaires les eaux en
tout cas les roches à quoi faire
continueraient à être polluées et donc
il y aurait toujours une rémanence de la
chlordécone aux Antilles
sans attendre cette disparition
naturelle et depuis de nombreuses années
mais là les pistes de recherche de
décontamination sont prometteuses dans
les bonnes nouvelles alors d'abord par
rapport à l'eau la pollution de l'eau de
consommation
et bien contrôlée grâce à des filtres de
charbon actifs qui sont performants et
si parfois il y a des non conformité
c'est que ces noms conformité c'est
qu'on n'a pas suivi
on n'a pas su on n'a pas changé assez
régulièrement les filtres donc ça avec
un remplacement régulier ça leur
permettrait d'éviter de temps en temps
des interdictions temporaires de
consommation d'eau et surtout d'éviter
aux Antillais de consommer des autres
sources qui elles sont polluées parce
qu'elles ne sont pas contrôlées polluées
je parle à la chlordécone ça pour l'eau
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour la
dépollution des sols pour l'instant les
scientifiques ont trois pistes
prometteuses d'abord autour de plusieurs
souches de bactéries les travaux sont en
cours pour stimuler cette dégradation
sur le terrain sachant que ce sont des
bactéries
martiniquaises ou guadeloupéenne donc
pas des bactéries qu'on a été chercher
ailleurs piste prometteuse deuxième
piste une piste de réducteur chimique
le nom c'est le fer zéro valent ils ont
montré leur efficacité sur la couche
superficielle du sol mais ne permettent
pas de limiter un transfert de la
chlordécone vernis de rosfert et même si
c'est très efficace et là le coup est
assez probabilité mais je dirais c'est
un état de savoir ce qui est efficace et
ce qu'il faut faire et c'est la
dépollution
peut avoir un prix ou pas et la
troisième piste c'est la séquestration
de la molécule par l'ajout de compost
qui est aussi un essai certains charbons
d'origine végétale notamment
issus des Sargasses spirolisés
permettent de réduire le transfert aux
plantes ce qui serait une très bonne
nouvelle si on pouvait allier sargas et
chlordécone donc ça ce sont des pistes
de recherche très prometteuses qui sont
aspect positif de l'analyse que j'ai
menée puisque la recherche a progressé
dans mon rapport je recommande surtout
que ces pistes soient testées sur le
terrain antillais à grande échelle sorte
d'élaboratoires et des petites surfaces
pour être confirmées et surtout pour ne
pas susciter de faux espoirs pour les
populations
et la deuxième limite c'est que les
scientifiques se sont rendus compte que
les la molécule de accordéon pouvait
être en partie
dégradée mais provoquait naturellement
des nouvelles craies de nouvelles
molécules et que celle-ci on doit aussi
maintenant les analyser pour savoir si
elle ne provoque pas une autre un autre
type de dangerosité
dans les déceptions et je parle de la
cartographie dès 2009 avec mon collègue
à leur président de l'OPE Jean-Yves le
déo nous avions recommandé une
cartographie complète des sols afin de
l'on puisse informer les populations des
sols qui sont pollués parce heureusement
tous les soldes de la Martinique et de
la Guadeloupe ne sont pas pollués par la
chlordécone et là son a constaté que
celle-ci avait été très peu pratiquée
parce que le choix qui était fait a été
que de faire des analyses du sol
uniquement fondé sur les analyses
gratuites qui sont proposées aux
agriculteurs et aux utilisateurs de
jardin familiaux ce qui fait que tout le
sol et même tous les sols uniquement
dans les zones contaminées n'ont pas été
analysés
dans le point positif c'est que ceux qui
ont accepté de faire tester les sols
savent maintenant ce qu'ils peuvent
cultiver ou pas
dès 2009 nous savions que seuls les
légumes racines seules les tubercules
étaient contaminés donc on peut manger
des légumes on peut manger des fruits
sans aucun danger on peut faire de la
canne à sucre et même par précaution on
coupe la canne à sucre à deux ou trois
centimètres au-dessus de la terre donc
plein de cultures peuvent quand même
être faites en Martinique et à
Guadeloupe et les agriculteurs s'ils
savent si leur seul est contaminé ou pas
peuvent adapter leur culture pour
l'élevage
là aussi ça a progressé en 2009 en
soupçonnait que les bovins et les autres
animaux puissent être contaminés là on
sait que la chlordécone il nageèrent
soit enfouissant dans le sol soit en
buvant de l'eau
de contamination est possible puisque il
suffit de déplacer les animaux sur des
terres non polluées par la chlordécone
ou dans un élevage hors-sol alors tout
dépend de la durée de vie d'un animal et
avant son abattage mais en tout cas un
outil d'aide à la décision qui peut
estimer la durée de décontamination
nécessaire à partir d'une prise de sang
très simple a été développée pour les
bovins le gros problème demeure les
produits de la pêche c'est le gros point
noir les seules solutions hélas demeure
pour l'instant l'interdiction de la
pêche et de l'aquaculture dans les zones
polluées
donc alimentation au bout de la chaîne
ce sont bien les les antillais et qui
sont qui peuvent absorber de la
chlordécone et donc là ce sont
uniquement les conseils de prévention
qui peuvent être efficaces en 2008 et
2009 on a le gouvernement avait lancé le
programme Jafa jardin familiaux qui a
permis d'accompagner des propriétaires
de jardin familiaux de leur proposer de
bénéficier d'une analyse gratuite de
leur sol de conseils agricoles et
nutritionnels qui permettent de limiter
leur exposition des informations
destinées au grand public ont été
largement émises et elle s'avère
efficace tels les plus charges généreux
des légumes qui permet de limiter la
gestion de chlore des cônes
mais les campagnes de contrôle des
produits demeurent essentielles elles
ont effectivement démontré que les
produits alimentaires
issus des circuits officiels sont
indemnes de chlordécone alors je me
souviens plus à hauteur de 81 combien
70% environ sur les contrôles tout ce
que l'on peut acheter et consommer dans
les produits
dans les circuits formels sont sans
danger le principal axe de progrès
concerne le contrôle des légumes des
volailles des œufs puisque c'est très
récemment que l'on nous parle des œufs
qui sont très contaminés vous savez que
les poules se promènent et elles fuisse
un peu partout des poissons et des
crustacés tout ce qui est issu de
l'auto-production et des circuits
informels ils sont inexistants alors que
ces produits peuvent être contaminés et
ne sont pas contrôlés et on me dit qu'il
y a pas moyen de les contrôler
dedans je doute un petit peu enfin
dernière bonne nouvelle les conséquences
scientifiques sur la santé humaine
s'améliore il y a 10 ans dans le cadre
de l'étude canari on avait et avait
constaté que 90% des adultes antillais
avaient été détecté avec de la chlordon
dans le sang chez 14% des Guadeloupéens
25% des Martiniquais la concentration
des pastels à valeur toxicologiques de
référence qui est fixée par landeces
c'est à dire le seuil en dessous duquel
sur une longue période le risque
d'apparition des faits néfastes dans la
population est jugé négligeable
mais la base de ces études est ancienne
ça fait plus de 10 ans et il apparaît
dans leur rapport on recommande qu'elle
soit mise à jour cette actualisation
pourrait notamment s'appuyer sur le
dispositif qui est issu d'un amendement
sénatorial proposé par notre collègue
victoire jasmin
cosiné par plusieurs membres de cette
délégation il permet à tous les
Antillais de faire dosser d'oser sa
concentration sanguine en chlore des
cônes
par contre je rappelle bien et surtout
les autorités sanitaires le rappellent
bien que c'est pas parce que l'on a de
la chlordécone dans le sang que ça
signifie que l'on va avoir une maladie
il semble que grâce à la chlordécone
clan desconomie
on pourrait avoir un dépistage massif
qui permettrait de savoir où on est
la pollution et la concentration de
chlore des cône chez les Antillais
puisque nos chiffres remondent à 10 ans
et en disant si on a bien suivi les
conseils alimentaires il se peut
effectivement que les nouvelles soient
meilleures et surtout ça permettrait
d'accompagner chaque antillais si la
chlordécone dans le sang pour pouvoir
mieux
les orientés et mieux les suivre
à vous tous qui êtes membre de la
délégation et qui est antillais moi je
me permets de vous inviter à effectuer
le taux de chlore d'économie dans le
sang afin de pouvoir communiquer et si
vous avez effectivement de l'accordéon
dans le sang de pouvoir suivre et vous
faire suivre de telle sorte que l'on
sache si les mesures de prévention qui
sont proposées sont efficaces
dans ce sens je vais proposer à la NSM
par exemple de pouvoir suivre toute une
population d'étudiants qui quitterait
les Antilles pour venir métropole
étudier et pouvoir voir si au bout d'un
an leur toute leur déconne dans le sang
a diminué ça serait vraiment bien
caractéristique
concernant les effets sanitaires
toujours
les études menées depuis 15 ans confirme
qu'il y a une présomption entre
l'exposition de la chlordécone et la
survenue des cancers de la prostate qui
seraient de plus 6 à 8 % selon le
professeur mutinier que vous connaissez
tous
aux Antilles cette maladie a donc été
inscrite pour les agriculteurs et les
salariés des bananes au tableau des
maladies professionnelles selon un
certain nombre de critères mais on en
parlera éventuellement tout à l'heure
pour ma part je regrette que le focus
sur le cancer de la prostate et aussi
sur
la fertilité masculine et conduit
pendant des années des études à négliger
des études sur d'autres formes de
cancers et en particulier sur les
impacts sur les femmes des études
viennent d'être lancées depuis peu mais
maintenant il est temps d'aller à de
sortir de de cette de ce focus sur le
cancer de la prostate sur la santé des
enfants l'étude de l'accord mère-enfant
timoun avec mis très rapidement en
évidence l'exposition de la peur des
freins un risque de prématurité mais
aussi un impact hormonal sur le
neurodéveloppement le poids et la taille
des enfants jusqu'à 7 ans même si le
professeur multinier la qualifie de très
modérée des études sont parues récemment
les impacts à l'âge péri pubertaire sont
dorénavant à l'étude
en parallèle de l'actualisation des
connaissances scientifiques à notre
disposition
le rapport de reste une analyse disons
critique de l'action de l'État qui s'est
manifestée à travers les trois plans les
quatre plans enfin les trois premiers
plans qui leur déconne qui sont succédés
depuis 2009 2008 pour ma part ils ont
subi ils ont souffert de nombreux
écueils les aspects environnementaux
économiques ont été négligés le pilotage
et le financement de la recherche
inefficace se limitant à une meilleure
connaissance des effets sanitaires les à
l'exposition de la quart d'école les
instances de gouvernance étaient trop
centralisées administrative avec une
faible association des autorités locales
et quant à la communication grand public
que je la qualifierai d'inefficace
cette différence défaillance conforte le
sentiment de colère et de défiance de la
population antillaise ce qui s'est
traduit
hélas par des difficultés d'adhésion au
dispositif et aux recommandations
alimentaires qui s'avère pourtant
efficace parce que je pense simplement
émise par les services de l'État le plan
chlordécone 4 qui a débuté l'année
dernière veut tirer un certain nombre de
ces enseignements j'espère nous espérons
tous qu'il sera enfin efficace il a
associé dans son élaboration les
instances de gouvernance et
collectivités locales les représentants
de la société civile les organisations
professionnelles et on a nommé un
coordinateur interministériel et enfin
un budget annuel un peu plus conséquent
un tiers de ce budget est consacré à la
recherche et enfin quelque chose que je
réclamais depuis presque 10 ans un
chaque ministre de la Recherche et je
présume que j'en ai eu sous les trois
présidents différents donc ce n'est pas
une question de couleur politique enfin
un appel à projet
uniquement consacré à la chlordécone a
été lancée par la nr
il faut plus de transparence avec la
publication annuelle du bilan du plan
pour afin afin de pouvoir éventuellement
le réorienter plus rapidement et pas
attendre à la fin
et dans les aspects positifs des actions
de formation pour les professionnels de
santé les enseignants et les échos
délégués ont été prévus
ceci vont pouvoir je l'espère jouer un
rôle de relais de confiance auprès d'une
population
qui sera peut-être plus sensible à leur
action donc l'idée par cet état des
lieux le rapport porte sur 24
recommandations regroupés autour de
quatre axes de
son principaux la recherche la
communication la chlore d'économie et le
suivi et l'évaluation du plan vous les
avez dans le rapport j'en ai évoqué
certaines au cours de mon intervention
je ne vais pas toutes les commander
commenter
concernant la recherche comme je vous
l'ai dit et la progresser dans tous les
secteurs même si les résultats ne sont
pas forcément à la hauteur des attentes
de la population
à noter que la biodiversité a été un peu
oubliée et qui ne serait temps d'avoir
une vision plus globale une vision ou un
Elf des impacts de la chlordécone et
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure des
dérivées nées de la dégradation ou des
effets cocktails de la chlordécone avec
d'autres pesticides
les solutions de remédiation des sols
continuent à me paraître prioritaire
afin de ne pas attendre la fin du siècle
pour que la cliente déconne disparaisse
le financement du Plan chlordécone 4
doit être poursuivi mais avec une
coordination des projets et j'en profite
il n'y en a aucun ici mais pour vous
dire toute l'admiration que j'ai pour
les chercheurs qui sont peu nombreux et
qui depuis 13 ans n'ont pas cessé de se
mobiliser alors qu'il n'avait pas de
financement pour leurs études
il m'apparaît primordial d'obtenir une
vision plus complète des risques
sanitaires sur toute la population et
pas simplement sur une catégorie
et même enfin ça je l'évoquais donc
heureusement donc les connaissances
actuelles
fournissent des nombreux outils pour
prévenir la contamination et la
minimiser encore faudrait-il trouver les
moyens de convaincre toute la population
de s'approprier ces solutions le rôle
des acteurs locaux le rôle de vous les
acteurs locaux de terrain me paraît
essentiel d'autant que vous connaissez
les réalités et les freins
socioculturels des Antilles la
communication doit absolument sortir du
cadre qui a été le sien jusqu'à présent
la chlore d'économie je le répète n'est
pas un outil prédictif mais c'est un
outil de dialogue avec la population
afin de rassurer les antillais et
d'adapter au cas par cas les
recommandations SAN itaires les
résultats obtenus doivent permettre
d'actualité les données sur la
contamination et j'estime que les deux
îles devraient avoir une approche plus
convergente de la chlorure d'économie et
que les capacités
des laboratoires d'analyses médicales
devraient être accrues il y a 13 ans il
y en avait aucun labo donc il y a quand
même un progrès mais ça fait quand même
13 ans
je conclurai ainsi ce qui est arrivé aux
Antilles doit servir de modèle à l'état
pour apprendre à gérer les pollutions à
venir que nous manquerons pas de
découvrir sur tous les territoires
français jusqu'à présent la liste des
erreurs a été plus longue que celle des
actions efficaces une vision globale à
long terme s'appuyant sur la recherche
et associant tous les acteurs et la
population est nécessaire à l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
merci chers Catherine pour ce second
exposé puisque tu as présenté ton
rapport le 3 mars dernier déjà donc mais
qui est important qu'on puisse avoir cet
échange avec nos deux délégations je
salue d'ailleurs à présence de notre
collègue député de Martinique qui nous a
rejoint Giovanni et William et je vais
maintenant vous donner la parole mes
chers collègues je crois que Dominique
Théophile a fait déjà une demande de
parole
bonjour à tous je tiens à saluer le
travail de Catherine sur le sujet c'est
un sujet qui a été évoqué plusieurs on
dirait au rythme de chaque mois on parle
du sujet ça vient un complément avec la
commission d'enquête menée par Serge Le
chimie et Justine Bénin
là je l'ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
à mon avis il y a un point d'alerte que
je voulais signaler et de prévention
vous avez des zones en Guadeloupe la
zone du Sud Basse-Terre et plus
précisément
Capesterre de Guadeloupe ou le tour en
tout cas de contamination et c'est le
la commune il y a le plus fort taux de
contamination sur le rivage vous avez de
la dessergas
les Sargasses contiennent de la
chlordécone
et pour pouvoir se débarrasser des
Sargasses il faut les épander à 20 cm
maximum ce qui fait que vous devez avoir
des surfaces pour pouvoir sécher les
Sargasses
donc point d'alerte sur la Grande Terre
par contre il n'y a pas de chlore
d'école si il y a un transport de
Sargasses sur la Grande Terre
et que vous et que les Sargasses
touchent le sol avec le lixisia
et dans ces zones là vous avez la nappe
phréatique donc point d'alerte sur le
transport et le stockage sur les zones
qui ne sont pas contaminées par la
chlordécone concernant les sargas qui
contiennent dans les zones
indiquées de la chlordécone donc point
d'alerte il y a quand même une solution
que j'avais évoqué dans le rapport
sargasque j'ai mené
la technique du liner c'est à dire que
si on souhaite stocker ses Sargasses là
pour faute de place
quand les stocke sur du liner style
liner de piscine bref avec une
récupération dans des fuites et brûler
le lixivia pour qu'à un moment le jus ne
puisse toucher le sol
là c'était un point que je ne vois pas
sur les rapports et qui très très
important et ça peut se faire très très
vite il suffit de camions de camion puis
dire bon allez on se débarrasse de là on
va sur la Grande Terre et en déverses
sur la nappe phréatique et donc vous
comprenez la catastrophe que ça peut
être sur
sur la transformation
des Sargasses en Chabot en charbon actif
pour éliminer la chlore des comptes
voyant un petit peu le circuit interne
c'est à dire lors des cône c'est orgas
là aussi il y a ce n'est plus une
expérimentation où on balbutie pour
savoir est-ce que ça marche ça marche
ça marche et d'ailleurs c'est
l'université de des Antilles avec
université au à Saint à Saint-Domingue
qui ont déjà expérimenté sur les fous
pyrolyse pour pouvoir mettre à l'échelle
sauf que les industriels ne peuvent pas
s'engager aujourd'hui parce que dans la
recherche il manque justement jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas si nous
aurons des Sargasses tout le temps et à
tout moment donc l'industriel hésite
pour pouvoir investir des millions sur
un produit le stock qu'il n'y ait pas de
stock après pour pouvoir
rentabiliser le le l'investissement donc
ça peut marcher puisque ça marche et
donc il suffit à mon avis de remettre
une couche pour que nous puissions
passer par l'expérimentation comme ça
mais passer comme vous l'avez dit
Catherine a
donc voilà ce que je voulais préciser le
point d'alerte et puis la confirmation
du charbon actif et sur le point aussi
de la sécurisation de la potabilité de
l'eau il y a un sortie bien évidemment
avant la distribution un contrôle ARS un
contrôle des fuites puisque l'eau ne
sort pas de la canalisation pour rentrer
au robinet ça passe toujours par ce
qu'on appelle chez nous le château d'eau
un point où et donc par conséquent il y
a peu de risques que ça puisse sortir
avec une contamination en chlordicone
tu as évoqué
le transport des Sargasses
j'avoue que personne ne m'en a nous en a
parlé pendant toutes les auditions je
sais pas si c'est s'il est prévu d'aller
vers la grande terre ou pas en tout cas
c'est pas un sujet qui a été évoqué
puisque nous on était vraiment que sur
la pollution de l'accordéon qui est dans
le sol qui est dans l'eau et des
transferts sur les plantes et des
conséquences sur l'homme
donc tu l'as les Sargasses pyrolysées
qui permettent de servir d'assolement
effectivement ça fonctionne c'est
saragaspard de l'université des Antilles
qui a mené cette cette étude moi je
crois en tout cas par rapport à la
décontamination des sols qu'il n'y a pas
une solution mais qui a plusieurs qu'il
faut plusieurs solutions il y en aura
peut-être deux il y en aura peut-être
trois il y en aura peut-être d'autres
qui arriveront mais il y a pas une seule
solution qui va permettre de tout
décontaminer puisque d'abord vous avez
des sols qui sont les endossols des
nudisols qui sont différents aux
Antilles et il faut pouvoir atteindre un
certain nombre de de zones puisqu'on
peut décontaminer le sol et donc faire
de la culture de légumes racines mais on
décompte à malin Rapallo donc il y a
plusieurs solutions à trouver alors par
rapport aux industriels et au Sargasses
je crois que si la pollution la
pollution de à l'accordéon est bien
reconnu par tout le monde et par l'État
bah il faut aussi que on y mette que
l'État ils mettent les moyens financiers
même si financent pas tout qui puisse
aider ou financer par différents biais
des entreprises qui se lanceront
là-dedans alors tu as évoqué des lots
moi ma grande préoccupation enfin
c'était des gens en 2009 c'était c'est
les autres sources qui sont pas survie
et contrôlés et j'ai cru comprendre que
les Antillais continuaient à aller se
servir en eau de source en étant
persuadé comme d'ailleurs beaucoup en
métropole que l'eau qu'on va boire en
montagne ou alors ou ailleurs serait
meilleur ce qui n'est pas forcément le
cas donc
en 2009 dans certains endroits où les
eaux de source en tout cas de bord de
route
était vraiment très contaminé
je me souviens de préfet qui avait
interdit complètement la consommation
qui avait bouché ses eaux moi je crois
qu'il faut que des contrôles et des
informations se fasse sur les autres
sources de telle sorte
d'éviter des contaminations
involontaires et en même temps les
autres sources et celles qui vont
alimenter éventuellement des animaux que
les animaux ne soient pas contaminés non
plus donc je trouve que ce soit en
matière d'eau donc c'est efficace en
matière alimentaire les contrôles sur
les circuits officiels fonctionnent bien
mais c'est tous les circuits officieux
enfin tous les circuits
qui existent aux Antilles qui ne sont
pas contrôlés et c'est
c'est cela sur lequel il faudrait
pouvoir porter l'effort
mes premiers mots seront pour féliciter
l'excellent travail qui a été mené par
notre cher collègue Catherine bocacha
c'est important vous avez déjà fait un
premier travail en 2009 il s'agissait de
l'évaluer et de voir comment les choses
avaient progressé c'est une démarche que
j'apprécie parce que souvent on peut
produire des rapports des dépositions
initagères et ne plus y penser 20 ans
plus tard là ça a permis de faire
un état en mode Bao maître évaluation de
ce qui se fait parce qu'effectivement il
y a quand même des choses qui se font
juste pour préciser que lors de la
plénière de l'Assemblée donc c'est pas
une motion qu'on a voté mais une vraie
délibération pour
provoquer une loi d'orientation de
programmation de sortie du clan des
cônes faut savoir que les plantes leur
déconne sont aléatoires si le
gouvernement qui décide de mettre en
place un plan le dot plus ou fortement
en budget et ça risque aléatoire on
n'est pas à l'abri de gouvernement qui
pourrait demain dire le clan des
conneries et on ne fait plus de plan que
l'on déconne donc le fondé dans la loi
aura un caractère à la fois obligatoire
et contraignant qui est porté par la loi
qui va permettre en tout cas au travers
de certains nombre de décrets de mettre
en œuvre une série de mesures
donc pour moi cet élément qui est porté
aujourd'hui
devra être versé au travail qui va
commencer puisque la collectivité de
Martinique à la fois réaliser les études
d'impact et l'exposer des motifs qui va
provoquer on sait pas encore c'est un
PJL ou une PPL demain pour porter porter
cette initiative parlementaire au
gouvernemental pour porter cette loi
mais en tout cas les conditions sont
réunies pour que ça aille très vite et
cette délibération a été votée à
l'unanimité tout bord politique confondu
je dis dernier à la plénière de de la
CTM euh l'autre chose concernant les
autres sources et un certain nombre de
tests qui ont commencé les autres
sources sont de plus en plus contrôlées
avec des avertissements qui sont donnés
donc au aux utilisateurs et puis on a
rajouté
depuis maintenant deux trois ans le
contrôle au robinet donc il y a
plusieurs dizaines de contrôle au
robinet qui sont faits chez le
consommateur puisque bon on pense que
l'autre avait au sang parfois des tuyaux
parfois avec des casses qui se font en
milieu
avec de la terre qui peut donc
contaminer l'eau et bien il a été décidé
par la RS de faire des contrôles au
robinet ces contrôles avec les
filtrations charbon qui sont mises en
place ça avait
de bonnes de bonnes tenues autrement dit
on boit une eau d'une potabilité
exceptionnelle en Martinique quant aux
pollution donc merci pour ce travail
Catherine on saura le faire prospérer il
le portait comme une contribution
importante au travail à venir mais c'est
une manière de travailler que j'aime
bien parce que le colon déconne
effectivement procu au chez nous une
série de fièvres à tous les niveaux et
en particulier pour ce non-lieu qui a
été prononcé récemment tant
parlementaire je ne vais pas ici porter
de jugement sur ce non-lieu les les
recours juridiques sont en cours mais
au-delà de cet aspect juridique
inacceptable pour les populations et ça
je le comprends et je l'accepte il y a
aussi de manière tout à fait souveraine
responsable à mettre en place un certain
nombre de mesures pour arriver à juguler
ce drame qui frappe Guadeloupe et
Martinique en particulier de
contamination des sols au clan des codes
et tu as ouvert la voie aussi Catherine
sur les autres pollutions il y a pas que
le clan des cône et un cocktail de
pesticides beaucoup de pesticides autour
d'utiliser parce que en agriculture
tropicale on est sujet à énormément de
maladies d'attaque phytosanitaire et il
faut régulièrement se battre contre ces
attaques en une nuit des champignons
peuvent vous décimer des champs de
tomates et effectivement la pression est
importante sur les agriculteurs et
l'utilisation de produits phyto est
assez important avec une baisse annoncée
entre dans
ce qui était considéré comme la culture
la plus polluante autrement dit la
banane qui a baissé aujourd'hui de 85%
ces utilisations de produits
phytosanitaires donc il y a des progrès
qui sont remarquables pas suffisant
certes mais sur le vous les recherches
en particulier pour avoir participé à
des à des réunions importantes sur le
Cloud icône et bien on voit bien que la
recherche s'est ouverte que certains
nombre de d'appels à projets sont
aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour et que
l'université des Antilles travaille de
manière extrêmement déterminée pour
prendre sa place dans la pré-claude
merci
merci merci Catherine effectivement
pendant tous les années j'ai continué à
être en contact avec en particulier des
équipes de chercheurs et j'avoue que
c'était assez désespérant quand je
recevais des mails ou des appels
téléphoniques des équipes de chercheurs
qui étaient à la recherche de 15000 ou
de 20000 euros pour continuer à faire
quelque chose et que même en écrivant et
en intervenant auprès de différents
ministres ces équipes là et elles
étaient pas très nombreuses
n'arrivait pas à voir leur financement
ils ont quand même continué ils ont
quand même progressé donc c'est
important tu as évoqué des produits
phytosanitaires alors moi je voudrais
vous renvoyer un excellent rapport qui a
été fait par la délégation d'outre-mer
il y a quelques années sur effectivement
l'agriculture en outre-mer
les produits
sanitaires et les normes européennes qui
sont
imposées qui sont imposés avec des
aberrations
qui font que on considère que les
enfants de nos territoires d'outre-mer
on dit Guadeloupe mais ailleurs
répondent aux doivent répondre
exactement au même critères que quand on
est dans la Creuse ou quand on est dans
les Pays-Bas alors que les saisons sont
pas les mêmes alors que on sait bien que
la température n'est pas les mêmes et
avec des aberrations qui fait que il y
avait un certain nombre de produits
naturels d'huiles essentielles et autres
qui pouvaient lutter contre certains
nuisibles mais en place les découvertes
par le sierrade enfin par l'INRA par des
organismes qui sont des organismes
d'état et qui n'ont qui n'avaient même
pas et qui n'ont pas eu les
autorisations d'être utilisées parce
qu'elle pouvait pas être utilisée dans
l'ensemble de l'Europe donc je me
souviens on avait essayé de bouger sur
ces thèmes là et là sans succès parce
que vous connaissez l'Europe et comment
elle est bloquée
sur un des premiers mais c'est aberrant
de ne pas tenir compte de la
cificité du climat des cultures c'est
pas les mêmes terres c'est pas les mêmes
produits et effectivement on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas dire zéro produit sinon
vous pouvez plus rien manger et vous
pouvez plus rien produire
Olivier
d'abord puis après Olivier
président mesdames messieurs a laissé
Nacer mesdames messieurs merci pour ce
rapport
pour également les recommandations
faites effectivement c'est une situation
qui doit qui doit aboutir à quelque
chose de concret et vous aborder ce qui
est important c'est à dire les
recommandations et vous avez tout à fait
raison les plans précédents n'étaient
pas efficaces et il y a lieu de les
renforcer notamment par le plan clore
des cône 4 mais aussi par les
initiatives locales telles que ce qui a
été fait par par la CTM donc en
Martinique
je souhaite aborder un point vous avez
parlé de la défiance de la population et
de l'utilisation des sciences humaines
pour justement
augmenter l'adhésion aux recommandations
je dirais aussi qu'il faut que les
sciences humaines soient utilisées pour
étudier et rechercher l'impact
psychologique
sous les populations ça on parle de
l'impact sanitaire sous le plan médical
il y a aussi un impact psychologique
imaginez-vous un instant que vous avez
une molécule dans votre corps qui ne
devrait pas y être même si elle ne vous
fait rien en prime de prime abord elle
est quand même là en vous et donc il y a
un préjudice qui est un préjudice
d'anxiété qui est présent qui est latent
et qui mériterait à mon sens d'être
étudié parce que nous sommes dans dans
des populations qui
ont du mal à comprendre et c'est pour ça
aussi qu'il y a cette défiance donc je
pense que les sciences humaines
seraient aussi
importante à travailler sur ça c'est à
dire le préjudice préjudice d'anxiété
parce que pour reconstruire une
confiance il faut
reconnaître sa responsabilité ça c'est
un autre pas néanmoins il faut étudier
ces risques psychologiques c'est c'est
pathologie psychologique parce que il y
a vraiment dans nos populations des
difficultés sur ce point en tout cas
merci pour le travail que vous avez fait
merci monsieur le député effectivement
les sciences humaines commencent
simplement à être intégré dans les plans
de financement mais dans les entretiens
les tables rondes que nous avons fait
pour ma part elles m'ont appris beaucoup
de choses
merci président cher Stéphane madame la
sédatrice chers collègue mesdames
messieurs merci beaucoup pour ce travail
très intéressant et de vous être
intéressé à une problématique importante
en Guadeloupe Martinique dans les
différentes recommandations que j'ai
parcouru sur mon trou rapidement
j'aimerais vous interroger sur une
problématique qui est importante me
semble-t-il c'est faire le lien entre
cancer et clore des cônes
quand à l'époque en 2018 nous avions
auditionné la ministre de la Santé de
l'époque Madame Agnès buza elle s'était
engagée devant la délégation d'outre-mer
à l'Assemblée nationale de lancer et
c'est l'une de vos recommandations des
appels à projets pour pouvoir constituer
encore plus scientifique de spécialiste
mondiaux qui pourraient très clairement
faire le lien entre cancer et
chlordécone
ça n'est pas si aisé parce que
souvenez-vous le président de la
République à l'Élysée ayant et on doit
lui donner acte de ça avait dit je
reconnais la responsabilité de l'État et
en même temps qu'il dit ça
il dit et ça avait un peu compromis ça
sa communication oui mais faut pas dire
que c'est cancérigène forcément alors
que il y a des présences sur fortes
fort probable qu'il y a un lien entre
cancer avec leur école mais par contre
le lien scientifique n'est pas
aujourd'hui établie donc pourquoi
j'assiste sur cet aspect là c'est que
une fois qu'on fait le lien de trois
cancer avec leur déconne
il va en découler un certain nombre de
conséquences pour les populations je
rappelle que je vois quelques hommes de
Martinique Guadeloupe ici sénateur
député on est exposé
j'allais arriver aux femmes quatrième
t'inquiète pas
pour les hommes j'allais parler du
cancer de la prostate nous sommes
oui nous sommes dix fois plus exposés
que n'importe quel autre population
mondiale 10 fois plus
voilà ça c'est un chiffre et discutable
et donc pour les femmes vous avez fait
référence à une enquête qui est terrible
sur les faits sur la collectivité pour
la cognitif notamment des jeunes filles
c'était friand donc ce lien entre
cancérigord je crois et fondamental
ayant droit investigué dedans parce
qu'on ne peut pas
détourner du regard cette vraie
problématique là qui aura des
conséquences sur l'indemnisation des
victimes et pas que celle qui ont
travaillé dans les champs de bananes
parce que comme ça s'est arrêté début 90
souvent ces personnes là étaient
étrangères n'ont déclarés où elles sont
décédées donc c'est pour ça que souvent
le ministère vous dit je comprends pas
il y a pas beaucoup de personnes qui
demandaient pour cause elle n'existait
pas où elles sont mortes par contre il y
a bien des personnes ici présentes qui
que ce soit moralement ou physiquement
subissent encore les problématiques de
la chlordécone ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point que j'ai surement là
encore sur sur les trop rapidement sur
l'identification
des terres
déconner la cartographie des terres
aujourd'hui le compte n'y est pas du
tout
vous l'avez dit donc c'est bien ce dont
je me doutais donc là je crois qu'on
doit vraiment aller plus dans le détail
parce que ça n'est pas encore
satisfaisant et plus généralement
il est important sur cet aspect là et
vous l'avez dit aussi je l'ai vu de
parler aussi de la pollution des mers
parce que une fois qu'on aura
éventuellement
envisager de dépolluer les terres
il faudra aussi se questionner sur les
mers et enfin pour ne pas être trop long
sur la dépollution des terres là aussi
c'est un vrai sujet on sait comment
faire nous avons des chercheurs en
Martinique Guadeloupe Université des
Antilles qui font un très beau travail
je pense aux professeur Gaspard mais pas
que
il faut dépolluer les terres et on sait
comment faire alors puisque les terres
responsables il doit indemniser les
victimes et d'évoluer les terres je ne
serai pas trop long mais quand même et
vous avez fait référence à ça sur ces
pratiques de pesticides européennes là
c'est un vrai scandale et quand on
voudrait nous dire qu'il ne faudrait pas
consommer local mais qu'il faudrait
consommer
des produits non chlordé ça ne peut pas
être la solution pour nous puisque on
veut tendre vers et ça nous a été
suggéré par le ministre des outre-mer et
de l'intérieur je tente vers le taux
suffisance alimentaire en tout cas la
souveraine est alimentaire et pour ça on
doit produire chez nous sur nos terres
qui ont été pollués aujourd'hui et qui
ne le sont pas encore en termes de
dépollution merci
alors très rapidement sur
l'identification des terres dès 2009
dans notre rapport on demandait qu'il y
a une cartographie complète des sols et
c'est ce que je déplore c'est qu'il y a
eu je suis en train de gérer 3,4 % du
territoire de la Guadeloupe et 9% en
Martinique qui ont été cartographiés
alors certes on sait bien que toutes les
terres n'ont pas été polluées puisque
c'est là où il y avait des plantations
et que c'était au pied de chacune de
chacun des bananiers qu'on mettait de
l'Atlant d'école mais entre 9% au
maximum des terres et l'ensemble des
terres je pense qu'on ne peut rassurer
les Antillais que lorsque l'on sera
effectivement pourra leur dire votre
terrain il n'est pas du tout pollué où
il est un peu pollué donc ça c'est
vraiment un point important et ce choix
de faire reposer la cartographie
uniquement sur les analyses volontaires
pour moi est une erreur même si sur
place on m'explique on pourrait pas
faire autrement
je suis pas d'accord avec vous monsieur
le député quand vous dites que on n'a
pas établi le rapport enfin qu'on n'a
pas travaillé sur le chlordécone et le
cancer c'est la moi ce que je déplore
c'est qu'on a travaillé depuis 12 ans 13
ans que sur le cancer et le cancer de la
prostate on n'a pas travaillé sur
beaucoup d'autres formes de cancer pour
savoir s'il y a des incidences ou s'il
n'y a pas
d'incidence la présomption entre le
l'accordéon et le cancer de la prostate
et bien établi et il est estimé par le
je crois que c'est des chiffres du
professeur multimié il est estimé entre
6 et 8% de cancer de la prostate qui
serait
qui serait
provoquée par
par l'accordéon dans notre rapport dans
les pages 50 51
les analyses qui sont faites montrent
que le taux de cancer son globalement
inférieurs aux Antilles par rapport à la
chlordécone pour le cancer du poumon
pour le cancer colorectum pour le cancer
du sein par contre qui a une
sur-incidence pour le col de l'utérus
pour l'estomac la prostate et les
myélones multiples donc il y a pas le
même type de cancer
et
il semble qui est effectivement pour
l'estomac pancréas chez les femmes une
exposition plus importante donc on a on
a quand même travaillé on peut pas dire
qu'on n'a pas que les scientifiques les
chercheurs n'ont pas travaillé sur le
cancer les incidences de la chlordécone
sur le cancer de
sans compter que le cancer de la
prostate avait été étudié auparavant
après l'accident qui avait eu à poil aux
États-Unis l'usine qui fabriquait qui
fabriquait la chlordécone et je pour mes
collègues qui n'ont pas suivi
complètement le dossier on a les
États-Unis ont fermé mais la chlordécone
a continué à être produite en sous-main
au Brésil et que la chlordécone est plus
grande quantités de chlordécone qui ont
été utilisés ça pas été aux Antilles ça
a été surtout les pays de l'Est
l'Allemagne enfin à l'époque du bloc
soviétique en Pologne en Allemagne de
l'Est en Hongrie et partout ailleurs la
chlordécone a été utilisée sur les
champs de pommes de terre pour lutter
contre le doryphore et en 2009 je suis
même allé voir les verres allemands pour
leur dire essayer de faire des
recherches dans vos terres puisqu'on
avait trouvé des traces dans l'eau de la
chlordécone aucun pays européen
qui font maintenant non pas partie de du
bloc soviétique n'a voulu faire une
quelconque recherche alors certes les
sols ne sont pas les mêmes c'est pas des
seuils
même type de sol sur les champs de sur
les grandes plaines mais quand même nous
au moins on a essayé de travailler
dessus alors que les autres ont préféré
complètement fermé les yeux pour tout ce
qui est maire je suis d'accord avec vous
on a aucune solution
hormis cette interdiction de pêche
[Musique]
pour pour les terres on s'est fait
je pense pour ma part je dis on a des
grandes il y a des grandes pistes de
recherche ce que je dis surtout c'est
qu'il faut que ces pistes qui sont
prometteuses auxquelles je crois comme
vous mais on les teste à grande échelle
pour être sûr que ça soit efficace et
pour qu'on donne pas de faux espoirs je
vois qu'il est 58 peut-être répondre à
une dernière question pour maintenir ton
agenda
juste Olivier serra voulait juste
compléter un propos et puis
pour ces réponses très précises il faut
vraiment qu'on soit précis sur un point
multigner son étude et discuter
scientifiquement n'est pas accepté je
veux dire c'est ça le vrai problème il a
fait une très belle étude et moi
j'aimerais bien le croire sauf que la
communauté scientifique internationale
le considère pas que le protocole
appliqué et satisfaisant pour faire en
lien et discutable entre cancer et clore
des codes premier point donc il faut et
ça c'est pas moi c'est je suis pas
spécialiste c'est Buzyn qui me l'a dit
ministre de la santé il faut lancer cet
appel à projet pour faire ce lien
discutable parce que multiné pour
l'instant c'est discuté c'est pas
valable on y va international même si il
y a une projection forte deuxième point
vous parliez de
des États-Unis comme moi elle s'est pas
comparable puisque ionexposition mille
fois plus importante à l'accord des
comptes du feu de cette explosion que
nous ou nous nous sommes exposés de
façon beaucoup moins importante donc il
est évident que lorsque vous êtes mille
fois plus exposé à la couleur des cônes
dans
des Etats-Unis il y a un lien
indiscutable par contre nous c'est pas
la cas c'est pas la même situation
puisqu'on a exposé de façon beaucoup
plus sourde et beaucoup moins importante
et c'est dans ce cadre là d'une
exposition lancinante plus faible mais
plus répétée et plus longue qu'on doit
faire ce lien avec leur déconne et ça
c'est important pour justement ne pas se
laisser troubler par diverses solutions
ou avancer scientifique qui n'en sont
pas encore et qui ne permettent pas
ensuite d'indemniser les victimes entre
cancer avec leur école le lien n'est pas
totalement établi aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Présidente
je tiens à féliciter déjà la rigueur du
travail et l'assiduité de la sénatrice
de Catherine pour Cassia au sein de
loupes parce que c'est un travail de
longue haleine et je tiens féliciter
cette rigueur là parce que si on est
aujourd'hui à ce stade c'est grâce à ces
travaux là et récemment encore a fait
l'année 2022 il y a eu un coloc à la
Martinique et à la Guadeloupe et j'ai
participé j'ai vu avec elle
rigueur il y avait à la fois les travaux
de lopex qui étaient valorisés mais
aussi les travaux des différents
chercheurs des chercheurs de la
Guadeloupe à certains ont été cités par
le député ici avant mais aussi
de partout on fait tous ceux qui
travaillent sur ces problématiques là
pour faire avancer à la fois la
connaissance parce qu'il y a eu un
moment donné c'est vrai un déni mais
maintenant je crois que il y a une
réelle volonté de faire avancer à la
fois au niveau de la recherche mais
aussi pour mieux comprendre les
problématiques liées à la santé à la
santé des hommes et des femmes donc
toutes les personnes qui ont bien
utilisé directement il y a quelques
années mais aussi tous ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui
impactés parce que les sols ou alors
quelques fois l'eau également il faut le
dire parce qu'il y a pas toujours les
contrôles et aussi le charbon actif pour
les filtrations donc il y a des
problèmes de traçabilité donc mais il y
a une rigueur dans la façon
d'appréhender les choses désormais sur
nos territoires seulement il faut
évidemment rassurer la population mais
aussi montrer des signes des travaux et
je crois que la méconnaissance également
permet également ne permet pas toujours
de rassurer les gens donc il y a des
problèmes de justice donc moi je ne vais
pas rentrer sur ce gentil là vais rester
sur tout ce qui concerne les travaux les
travaux de lopex ces travaux
scientifiques les avancées donc ce que
je regrette c'est surtout les
conséquences sur la valeur du foncier
concerné et au moment où on parle
beaucoup de la souveraineté alimentaire
notamment sur nos territoires donc il y
a il est nécessaire que l'on puisse plus
que jamais rassurer et poursuivre les
travaux concernant l'analyse des sols
partout sur le territoire et l'usage de
l'eau est particulièrement de l'eau
agricole parce que bon en fonction de
cela également donc il y a une il faut
vraiment qu'il y ait une traçabilité il
faut également que l'on puisse avec les
différentes recommandations en tenir
compte pour rassurer mais porter à la
connaissance aussi des populations
concernant Guadeloupe à la Martinique
parce que ça manque énormément donc j'ai
été à la Martinique il y a quelques mois
et il y avait une grande méconnaissance
après il active
madame la sénatrice commercial et à
participer à des travaux
je ne sais plus si elle était allé ou
pas mais en tout cas il y avait des
travaux prévus à la Martinique et je
crois que la méconnaissance contribue
également à créer aussi plus de
difficultés donc il faut
poursuivre c'est vrai il faut améliorer
la communication et concernant les liens
de causalité il y a peut-être aussi à
dire ce qui est vrai ou faux parce que
là aussi le fait de ne pas toujours
donner l'information ou même pas mettre
à disposition intégralité des
informations
contribue pas à améliorer effectivement
la connaissance de la population
s'agissant des tests concernant le
dosage
de la chlore d'économie là aussi il
faudrait qu'il y ait plus de personnes
qu'il y ait pour le moment c'est
disponible on peut on peut faire à la
fois à la Martinique donc il faudrait
aussi que la population y compris
nous-mêmes que nous puissions faire ces
tests là pour donner plus d'informations
et mieux comprendre
qui sont les personnes réellement
impactées et pour quelles jury enfin
donc il y a quand même depuis c'est
assez intéressantes qui sont proposées
donc le travail de l'opexia salué parce
que c'est à la fois les députés et les
sénateurs qui contribuent à ces travaux
là et je crois que même si au niveau des
ARS au niveau de l'État il y a des
avancées mais il faut vraiment que
l'ensemble
des travaux qui sont aujourd'hui les
nôtres mais qui sont aussi
des chercheurs devraient je crois être
pris en compte réellement pour que pour
la connaissance des différentes
populations et pour qu'il n'y ait toutes
les fantasmes s'agissant de la partie de
la justice comme je dis je ne vais pas
revenir sur ça mais sur ses
connaissances là il est important que
nous fassions connaître
l'intégralité de ce que vous proposez
merci beaucoup et félicitations pour ce
travail et entre l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat merci merci victoire
moi j'ai salué tout à l'heure
les tests gratuits qui ont d'économie
qui me paraissent essentiel et qui me
paraît surtout essentiel pour pouvoir
maintenant savoir quel est le degré
exactement de contamination des
populations puisque les tests ils
remontent à 10 ans
on sait qu'on a eu des évaluations comme
quoi 75% de la population suivait des
conseils alimentaires donc si 75% de la
population suit des conseils
alimentaires normalement la déconne dans
le sang devrait effectivement
disparaître par contre ce que avez du
mal à comprendre c'est pourquoi alors je
sais bien que c'est chacune des
collectivités qui a décidé les modalités
d'implant d'économie mais ça passe mal
de savoir pourquoi il y a une pratique
en Martinique et pourquoi il y en avait
une autre en Guadeloupe et à mon avis
les deux pratiques sont bonnes mais il
faudrait que toutes les deux soient
appliquées de la ensemble c'est à dire
que tout le monde puisse avoir accès aux
tests de chlore d'économie sang
éventuellement passer par un médecin
comme en Guadeloupe et que par contre
tous les résultats puissent être
accompagnés comme vous avez fait le
choix en en Guadeloupe donc à mon avis
il faudrait que les deux ARS se mettent
d'accord et puis on puisse avoir une
approche
identique et qui permettrait
effectivement de mieux accompagner la
population moi le gros enfin tu l'as
évoqué le gros souci c'est comment faire
passer les informations
à la population et là pour ça il faut
effectivement que ça soit par rapport à
des personnes qui sont crédibles et pour
l'instant moi je dis l'État et même
les scientifiques ne sont pas donc il
faut réussir
à informer à rassurer
puisque
monsieur le député serva parlait
d'alimentation mais on peut manger on
peut manger en Martinique en Guadeloupe
il y a des terres qui sont pas pollués
il y a que les légumes racines qui sont
pollués on peut développer des arbres à
pain on peut il y a des haricots les
bananes
cessons de mettre ola sur les bananes
alors que maintenant c'est de la banane
propre où il y a très peu de pesticides
et il y a beaucoup moins de produits de
bananes des Antilles qu'il n'y en a sur
les pseudos bananes bio du Costa Rica ou
d'ailleurs on a des on a des atouts mais
la communication
pour moi a été un échec et je pense que
c'est ça qui est très âme qui est
maintenant important avoir de la
transparence et savoir mieux s'informer
la population
si je peux ajouter quelque chose
Monsieur le Président concernant les
deux les deux pratiques alors pour avoir
dans ma vie antérieure était responsable
du laboratoire CHU au niveau de la
microbiologie alors la procédure qui est
pratiquée en Guadeloupe c'est celle qui
est je dirais la plus conforme dans les
textes mais il est vrai que à la
Martinique ils ont commencé très tôt à
faire les tests et beaucoup de européens
ont eu l'occasion de faire différents
à l'époque parce que il y a un
laboratoire dans la Martinique qui avait
commencé à faire des tests de cette
manière là alors l'avantage de faire
avec avec une ordonnance c'est qu'il y a
peut-être pas encore le suivi qu'on
aurait souhaité mais pour il faut qu'il
y ait une demande d'analyse la prise en
charge est faite c'est comme ça que
c'est fait et pour la traçabilité et
pour la pour une très bonne traçabilité
des résultats et avoir un médecin
traitant donc en ce moment après
effectivement
mis en place des procédures pour suivre
les personnes et leur donner en fonction
des résultats à leur donner des conseils
pratiques sur leur alimentation il y a
quand même des
leviers avec le plan 4 ça commence mais
je crois que quand on fait et qu'on a un
médecin traitant le médecin peut lui
aussi
donner des informations suivent et les
données les données qui concernent la
personne dans le dossier dans son
dossier médical il y a une meilleure
traçabilité donc pour la demande il faut
la demande donc ici la prescription
médicale en général c'est ce qui est
prévu dans la législation vigueur faut
une prescription médicale pour quel que
soit l'analyse c'est à dire que vous
allez faire
un examen que ce soit
parce que vous rentrez à l'hôpital il y
a une prescription pour le laboratoire
même quand vous arrivez aux urgences
c'est les urgences font une prescription
et demande mais en externe également
c'est comme cela et pour le suivi la
traçabilité et dans le dossier médical
comme ça vous avez votre dans votre
dossier toutes les informations
qui vont rester la durée qu'il faut en
tout cas de façon confidentielle donc il
y a à mettre uniformiser les pratiques
et les mettre de façon conforme tout
simplement merci
merci et comme nous dépassons l'horaire
déjà depuis quelques minutes je vais
quand même laisser la parole à Victoria
nurel pour une dernière intervention je
préfère obtenir tout le monde ce sera la
dernière en l'occurrence pour pouvoir
tenir nos délais et respecter le
Président je suis désolé d'être arrivé
en retard je suis président du groupe
d'amitié France pays du Sud donc j'étais
avec un ministre de la Défense
d'Argentine et donc je n'ai pas pu
suivre d'exploser dans d'autres
collègues progressia on s'est vu lors du
colloque en Guadeloupe et j'avoue que
j'attendais avec quelqu'un patience ce
travail là c'est opus là
parce que je trouve que le PEPS fait du
bon travail ce prestigieux et c'est
reconnu et donc
je prendrai peut-être un peu plus tard
mieux connaissance des recommandations
il y en a beaucoup
on a 24 ça veut dire l'ampleur du
travail et la complexité de la question
j'avoue avoir été étonné et je le dis
mais je mentais déjà ouvert à notre
collègue procacia que après 24 ans après
la première alerte faites par Monsieur
Pierre marécalinera en Guadeloupe sur
cette affaire là les scientifiques ont
explosé devant nous
leurs travaux est-ce qu'il m'a un peu
étonné c'est que nous en sommes toujours
chez les lenteurs de la science et il
faut donc être patient mais à la
décomposition de la structure de la
molécule
et ça m'a un peu étonné et comme
conclusion et j'avais posé la question
on continue à dire c'est cette siècle
de présence dans le sol et de
dégradation d'autres siècles il y a même
un scénario dans leurs études sur 47 ans
et
on avait échangé très rapidement et très
sommairement pour dire finalement que
Dieu que à la fin du siècle ça devrait
avoir un peu
disparu ou en tout cas
ce serait plus soutenable et plus
supportable pour les populations moi je
tiens la conclusion quand je regarde le
point corde déconne 4 et je les dis au
ministre monsieur karenko il y a une
super propagande faite par le
gouvernement je comprends ça que
lorsqu'on fait de la politique il faut
défendre ses actions on fait quand même
je trouve que c'est beaucoup et que en
termes de moyens donnés à la recherche à
la recherche fondamentale à la recherche
développement il y a encore beaucoup à
faire et que le calcul fait en disant
vous donne 91 millions sur 7 ans
lorsqu'on fait le calcul c'est moins
qu'avant 2015
2011 il y a là un problème de
concentration de moyen il y a un
problème de communication il y a un
problème de d'appel à projet
j'ai vu la première recommandation on
parle d'appel à projet je rappelle que
Madame business était engagée cela n'est
mort qu'après les premières études dites
épidémiologiques que on aurait un
protocole scientifique
qui serait lancée des études
approfondies qui seraient lancés et bien
après on l'a pas fait et donc moi je
demande que les recommandations je vais
en prendre mieux connaissance
soit suivi j'espère que ces
recommandations là celles de Lopez
contenu de la qualité des gens qui
travaillent que le gouvernement va s'en
inspirer et que on va un peu rectifier
je finis sur une chose c'est vrai c'est
pas le travail de lopex mais on a
demandé des choses simples au
gouvernement de dire il y a des enquêtes
et des poursuites pénales et je m'arrête
pas Président je sais que on est où déjà
au-delà de l'heure ok les gens vont
poursuivre sur le plan pénal on a
demandé à ouvrir négocier que le parquet
le fasse c'est possible
et ce que certains défendeurs n'ont pas
voulu faire c'est de dire ce qui existe
pour l'amiante c'est-à-dire le préjudice
d'anxiété et bien en plus l'invoquer et
que apparemment il suffirait de
l'arrêter pour faire figurer clore alors
que il y a amiante on n'a pas besoin de
bousculer la législation il suffit de ça
pour dire et bien que ce qui est se fait
sur le plan pénal on poursuit mais sur
le plan
civile on peut invoquer le président
d'angoisse il y a une première chose une
première plainte ils ont été déboutés
par ces fonds déclarés recevable mais
appel a été interjeté je pense que si le
gouvernement veut faire avancer la cause
rassurer les populations éviter la
désinformation que l'on voit et que l'on
entend et bien peut-être il faut ouvrir
les possibles et permettre aux gens de
mieux se défendre en tout cas merci je
j'en ferai mon miel
simplement sur la molécule et la
dégradation avec Jean-yves le déo vous
avez bien connu
Jean-Yves et moi on l'avait qualifié
Daniel chimique et c'est sans doute que
pour cette raison que au bout de tant
d'années il y a pas encore vraiment de
solutions mais aussi comme alors
deuxièmement sur les équipes de
chercheurs il y a hélas peut
d'équipe qui travaille sur la
chlordécone puisque comme j'ai dit
partout dans les pays de l'Est personne
n'a voulu les expédies personne n'a
voulu rechercher et travailler donc là
dans le dans les équipes scientifiques
j'ai vu qu'il y avait quelques Canadiens
qui avaient quelques autres personnes
c'est une ouverture mais ça n'intéresse
pas des autres
les autres chercheurs puisque la
chlordécone est vraiment recherché
uniquement les incidences que aux
Antilles donc on peut pas avoir une
communauté
les scientifiques aussi développé que
sur sur d'autres cas et je le dis et je
le redis bah les chercheurs j'ai
retrouvé un certain nombre de personnes
qui étaient déjà là en
2007-2008-2009 et qui n'ont pas
abandonné malgré le peu de financement
donc là c'est vrai que c'est important
c'est que le financement de la recherche
ça soit pas un coup de lancer dans l'eau
c'est vrai que certains scientifiques
m'ont dit on espérait pas avoir un tel
un thème financement
mais que ça soit pas un goût dans l'eau
il faut que ce soit régulier permanent
jusqu'à ce qu'on aboutisse à des
solutions parce que moi je crois dans la
science je peux une scientifique mais je
crois dans la science et je pense que
c'est à travers eux et à travers la
science répandue sur tous les secteurs
que l'on pourra essayer de régler ce
problème
en tout cas merci de vos questions et de
votre attention
merci chers Catherine de la qualité de
ces travaux et puis de ta volonté
persistante de pouvoir de vouloir les
suivre et moi j'avais participé et j'en
termine en février 2022 à l'audition à
laquelle tu m'as invité j'avais été
étonné par le bricolage nécessaire pour
nos scientifiques pour obtenir des
financements et la nécessité absolue
qu'on puisse financer en bloc la
recherche fondamentale sur ce sujet et
je pense que ça a été rappelé à
l'instant je crois qu'il faut vraiment
insister auprès des autorités
gouvernementales sur ce ça c'est des
choses qui me paraît qu'ils ne
comprennent pas effectivement et
pourtant c'est fondamental la recherche
a besoin de financement massif pour
trouver des solutions sur ce dossier
comme sur d'autres mais en l'occurrence
c'est celui qui nous a intéressé merci
beaucoup je vous propose de lever la
séance merci de votre présence et merci
à nos collègues députés de la
participation également